[Musique]
la stratégie de prévention et de lutte
contre la pauvreté était au cœur de la
séance plénière du département en 2019
avec le soutien de l'État la
collectivité mais en place une série de
dispositifs et d'actions en faveur des
publics fragiles afin de permettre leur
intégration et favoriser le retour à
l'emploi des personnes en situation
d'exclusion par exemple des actions de
médiation sociale les éducateurs de rue
sur le terrain je veux parler des
actions d'insertion pour les publics en
difficulté l'aide aux bénéficiaires du
RSA pour mieux s'insérer je veux parler
de la caravane d'accès au droit à les
République en grande difficulté pour
leur permettre d'accéder à l'endroits
sociaux je peux parler de l'aide
alimentaire un plan pauvreté qui s'est
construit autour de mesures socles mais
aussi avec des initiatives spécifiques
pour notre territoire comme ces deux
nouvelles caravanes d'accès aux droits
et à l'information qui vont être
déployés objectifs à mener les services
du département au plus près depuis le
mois de juin 2022 on a lancé la première
caravane d'accès au droit et au fil des
mois on a pu tirer un peu donc les
enseignements de cette expérience et
aujourd'hui on a on passe à trois
caravanes donc deux qui sont nés vers
tout ce qui touche au social l'accès au
droit dans le domaine de l'action
sociale pour les personnes âgées les
personnes en situation de handicap les
jeunes aussi bien évidemment et là avec
les deux nouvelles caravanes on aura
aussi une caravane tournée vers le
médico-social tout ce qui touche aux
actions de prévention santé ce plan
pauvreté se termine en 2023 avec près de
37 millions d'euros qui auront été
consacrés à faire baisser le taux de
pauvreté à la Réunion deux fois
supérieure à la moyenne nationale l'État
et le département continueront leurs
actions en 2024 avec un pacte local des
solidarités et on est déjà en train de
travailler avec un diagnostic
territorial qui permet de voir ce qu'on
a réussi ce qui va bien ce qu'il va
falloir améliorer et puis il y aura donc
à partir de 2024 un pacte local des
solidarités j'espère qu'on pourra le
signer avant la fin de l'année au début
de l'année prochaine avec monsieur le
Président les élus ont également validé
le compte de gestion et le compte
administratif 2022 une motion relative à
la taxation des alcools et du tabac a
également été porté par les élus
[Musique]